in this video I want to talk about the
difference between a nucleotide and
acquiesce I'd so think that some people
get confused about hopefully I clear
things up just now so a nucleotide has
three components those three components
are a pentose sugar a nitrogenous base
and a phosphate group that's it that's
the basic idea of the pentose sugar can
either be ribose or deoxyribose the
nitrogenous base is either a purine or a
pyrimidine which we'll talk about in a
later video the phosphate groups we can
have 1 2 3 so with the phosphate group
or groups right we can have 1 2 or 3
phosphates so how does that look
so it looks like this so here we have a
nitrogenous base attached to a pentose
sugar a fart which is a five carbon
sugar so this here is a pentose sugar
with the five carbons one prime two
prime three prime four primary
five prime this can be ribose or
deoxyribose like I just mentioned so
what determines that is the two prime mo
h here a two prime of h would be a
ribose right or if it was just a
hydrogen instead of an O H group then we
would have in that case a deoxyribose
that's something we covered earlier when
we cover carbohydrates so basically what
goes on to that two prime carbon
determines whether it's a ribose or
deoxyribose third thing of course is the
phosphate group I've only drawn one here
but there can be up to three like I
mentioned it one two or three
essentially what this is this is the
nucleotide now what is a nucleoside in
comparison pretty similar
it actually has a pentose sugar which of
course again can be oops
can be ribose or deoxyribose and have a
nitro
this base which again can be a purine or
a pyrimidine but there is no phosphate
group that's basically the difference we
still have a nitrogenous base here
attached to the one prime carbon of the
pentose sugar we still have of course
the pentose sugar again can be ribose or
deoxyribose but at the five prime end we
no longer have a phosphate we just have
a ch2oh just less though the sugar has
not been affected there at the five
prime carbon that's essentially the
difference Chintu place at a nucleotide
what you'll also notice is that
sometimes nucleotides are called
nucleoside phosphates which is basically
because their nucleus sides with
phosphate groups right so that's
basically it a simple way to remember is
that nucleotide has a letter T in it T
for three components t3 and nucleoside
has just one component less so you
subtract one component and you're left
with a nucleoside that's basically it I
hope that was helpful
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email at moof University
at gmail.com see the description below
for more details thanks for watching